abel leaders jeunes johnny hallyday
était leur idole il a marqué leur
enfance
il les a fait danser et chanter alors
ils ont voulu l'honorer à leur façon les
fans de la légende du rock français sont
venus de tout le pays pour se recueillir
un instant aux abords de sa maison en
banlieue parisienne souvent très ému
comme stéphanie meurs je sens du jeu
sans deuil encore quelques jours voir si
c'est pas plus j'ai perdu comme comme si
quelqu'un de ma famille fans de la
première heure
yves besson et andré duval sont venus à
l'eau pour lui rendre hommage
plus qu'un chanteur johnny c'est pour
eux un mode de vie ils l'avaient dans la
peau lisse et mon dieu mon dieu à moi
voilà à dieu si l'ubs du vote attendu
chez a croisé celle du prof
il était réservé un petit mythe mais
quelqu'un de simple vraiment très simple
quand il était sur scène c'était une
bête de scène
plus qu'une buck à marnes-la-coquette où
il est revenu s'installer pour mener
auprès 10 y est son combat contre le
cancer
johnny hallyday était un habitué de se
restaurent
m
aujourd'hui son portrait y est en
évidence sa musique il tourne en boucle
et son nom sera bientôt sur le menu
on va reprendre un plate et dont il
était fan c'était le foie de veau qui
nous demandaient pour lui de faire
spécialement déglacer au vinaigre de
framboise
il apparaît sur les planches pour la
première fois dans les années 60
beaucoup ne voient tant donné à l'idée
qu'une étoile filante
mais le chanteur ayez des débuts a su
s'adapter et perdurer sa carrière
s'étend sur près de 60 du 2000 titres
enregistrés et 100 millions d'albums
vendus souvent éprouvé par la vie qu'il
menait est en s'aimant il remonter
chaque fois sur scène avec passion à tel
point que ses fans le pense est
invincibles immortels lui même
admirateur avoué de johnny emmanuel
macron voient en lui un modèle
j'ai souvent dit qu'il fallait des roues
donc un pays soit grand c'est parti de
dire aux français johnny c'est donc un
monument français qui disparaît
aujourd'hui mais ses chansons elle à
coup sûr lui survivre ici jean françois
bélanger radio-canada marnes-la-coquette